on Sunday LGBT protesters decided to
march through Los Angeles shutting down
traffic as they went before meeting up
in gay Mecca West Hollywood where they
were treated to speeches from House
Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi Los Angeles
Mayor Eric Garcetti and of course RuPaul
but the theme of the day was not
tolerant and diversity it was hatred for
president Trump resist stickers
festooned garbage cans and telephone
poles people milled about an anti-trump
t-shirts in fact the usual pride march
was March was recast into a resist march
against the Trump administration which
is actually kind of weird given the
trumpets Pro gay marriage and is the
first politician to enter the White
House with that position monday marked
the first anniversary of a jihadist
massacring patrons at normal and O gay
nightclub an event from mark by stating
quote a radical Islamic terrorists
targeted the nightclub not only because
he wanted to kill Americans but in order
to execute gay and lesbian citizens
because of their sexual orientation it's
a strike at the heart and soul of who we
are as a nation it's an assault on the
ability of free people to live their
lives love who they want and express
their identity Trump is the first major
Republican politician to publicly lot -
gave a gay rainbow flag but Trump is
also the first Republican politician can
be honor of watching an LGBT March morph
into a movement against impersonally all
of which shows that identity politics
been wet is more of a strategy than a
principle that hiren stew the notion of
protecting supposed minority victims
well the less maintains that government
must be bigger and stronger and more
invasive in order to protect the right
to various political identity groups and
while left polarizing those identity
groups for political purposes the truth
is that identity politics is a mask for
leftism not an outgrowth of it if
identity politicus identity politics for
truly organic if dividing Americans by
identity groups truly led them to
coalition or politics you'd expect
alliances to ship LGBT Americans for
example might support from in larger
numbers than they've supported other
Republicans but exit polls show Mitt
Romney won more LGBT votes by solid
eight point margin than Trump did so
what's all this about
leftism panders to various
intersectional groups by positing
special benefits for them to be a
government but if the interest of the
groups don't run in favor of West ISM
leftism wins out anyway in low in other
words most LGBT voters are prime
leftists not single issue identity
politics voters leftist pandering to
identity politics is very often a
political ploy designed to grant
individuals a feeling of solidarity with
fellow identity group members but it's
not an actual principled opposition to a
candidate based on that candidates
adherence to the identity groups
priorities all of which means that it's
foolish for conservatives to engage in
identity politics accounts for the left
for the left each identity group is a
brick already stacked in the leftist
wall merely cemented in place with
identity group politics the right we can
try to chip away at the cement but the
brick is still going to be part of the
leftist wall instead conservatives
should try to blow up the wall
completely we should try to treat people
as individuals rather than as members of
identity groups destroy the notion of
people as atoms in broader bricks to
begin with identity politics is
dangerous it's more of a tool than an
end game the left knows that which is
why LGBT March can turn it into an
anti-trump March at the drop of a hat
even if Trump is fine with Caitlyn
Jenner using the women's bathroom at
Trump Tower I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
all right tons to get to so it's hurting
general Jeff sessions is supposed to go
before the Senate tomorrow and open
hearing very smart of attorney general
sessions will talk about that will talk
about Trump actually getting some things
done Republicans actually getting some
things done while the media are busy
focused on the Comey mania but before we
get to all of that first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at Rennes
calm so in the United States there is a
home burglary every 13 seconds most of
them happen in broad daylight the way
that he usually works is somebody rings
the doorbell to make sure that you're
not home and then they break into your
house well the way to prevent that is
ring calm because now with ring they hit
the doorbell and immediately signals
your phone and then you can actually get
on the phone and you can talk to the
person together under the doorbell so
they don't know that you're home you can
see from your ring video camera who
exactly is at the door for me it's great
because I'm very safety conscious that
means that I want to know who's the gate
before I open up the gate and that's
what ring allows me to actually see the
person at the gate before that plus they
have a new ring of security kit which is
an advanced motion detection technology
and protects your entire property it's a
ring video doorbell for the front door a
ring stick up cam Wireless weatherproof
HD camera to keep an eye on other parts
of your property everything installs in
minutes I've done it myself when they
work together they provide 24/7
monitoring of your entire home whether
you're in the living room or when there
are thousands of miles away we use it in
our house all the time when I'm
traveling people don't know that I'm
traveling obviously with regard to
ringing on the doorbell and I can tell
who's there my wife is very safety
conscious is well we use ring all the
time ring calm / Bend that's ringing
calm / bed and you get one hundred and
fifty dollars off that ring of security
kit when you go to ring calm / bed right
now again use that flash pens that they
know that we've sent you and also so you
get that one hundred and fifty dollar
discounts on the ring of security kit
okay so lots to get to about in terms of
the fallout from the from the Comey
testimony last week and again the Cobie
testimony sort of did two things number
one thing it did was it got rid of the
Trump Russia coalition narrative so if
you recall the democratic narrative was
Trump had worked with Russia to steal
the election and then after stealing the
election Trump had fired James Comey in
order to prevent that from coming out
that was left's theory and that has been
completely blown away by the Comey
custom
that's the upside even Democrats are now
acknowledging openly there's no evidence
of Trump Russia collusion this story is
falling apart Joe Manchin senator from
West Virginia he said as much on the
sunday shows do you agree with this
conclusion that the president has
reached there was no evidence of
collusion you know we haven't seen any
of that whatsoever George we've been
looking and showing everything that they
possibly have that has not led to that
okay so again I think it just
demonstrates that the left narrative on
this whole thing has fallen apart beyond
that it's also obvious that there's a
second aspect of this narrative that is
now being drawn out by the left so the
West is now pivoting okay it's like that
episode of Friends where Ross is trying
to get a couch up the stairs need your
shouting Vivat Vivat well that's where
we are right now the Democrats are now
pivoting off of the Trump Russia stuff
and now pivoting toward the trunk Flynn
stuff so the most damning part of commis
testimony and the part that was
apparently codified in a memo was this
part that says that Trump essentially
brought Comey into a room by himself
told everybody else to lead attorney
General Sessions to leave told DNI
Coates to leave told everybody get out
and then turn to Comey and said I hope
you can find your way clear to letting
Flynn go and coming since he took that
as a directive well a couple of things
number one obviously he didn't really
take it it's directive because you
didn't slow down a splint investigation
but what the left would say is OK from
meant that as directed Comey made out of
taking it seriously enough to act as the
director but the fact that he was fired
over it demonstrates that this is
obstruction of justice and the fact that
he said the same thing to Dan Coates the
Director of National Intelligence and
the same thing to the National Security
Agency leader Mike Rogers he's had the
same thing you know that he wanted to
let Quinn go he said it to all these
people that means ass obstruction of
justice so I think that it is worthwhile
now for you to understand just what
obstruction of justice is before we get
to the less kind of falsification of
what obstruction of justice is because
the left is all over this thing the left
is trying to claim now that Trump has
committed some sort of crime I want to
go through the actual law so Professor
Alan Dershowitz said last week that
there is no obstruction of justice said
quote the president could have told
Comey your commands it directed to stop
the prosecution against Flynn the
president has the right to do that
Comey acknowledges that he says in a
statement that historically historically
we presidents have done this at the
Justice Department so there's a fair bit
of legal debate over whether whether
professor Dershowitz is correct about
this but the general idea is the FBI
director works for the president the
president can fire whoever he wants
remember Nixon was not actually
prosecuted criminally for obstruction of
justice he was impeached and it's
important to keep this in your mind okay
because when you talk about impeachment
Trump does not have to have committed
technically a crime in order to be
impeached all that has to happen is the
Congress thinks he's done something bad
enough to impeach him hey you don't have
to be convicted of a crime in order to
be impeached the reason that's worth
noting is one the left when they claim
that Trump did something illegal they
can be wrong and still try to impeach
and to just because Trump didn't do
anything illegal doesn't mean that he
was acting very smart or good with
regard to FBI director Comey now Trump
obviously has the right to fire the FBI
director whether he has the right to
intimidate the FBI director is another
story so there are three statutes but
here's the problem there are three
statutes that basically cover
obstruction of justice federally there
are three statutes none of them appear
to apply in this case none of them
appear to apply to President Trump even
if you took the most egregious Comey
like reading of what Trump was saying
they even he took the most egregious
reading and he said what Trump really
meant was you better go out this window
or I'm going to fire you right even if
Trump said that it's not clear it's
obstruction of justice so here are the
three provisions of federal law one is
18 US Code 1503 this is called the
Omnibus clause the Omnibus clause with
regards an obstruction of justice covers
quote corruptly or by threatening letter
or communication influencing or impeding
or endeavoring to influence obstruct or
impede the due administration of justice
so that sounds pretty bad right because
if you assume there's an FBI
investigation going on and he's trying
to threaten to influence then that's
obstruction but the clause legally
requires a pending judicial proceeding
so it's not enough for there to be an
FBI investigation it actually has to be
like a trial going on and then you try
to threaten the prosecutor right that
would be obstruction of justice but we
don't know of any pending judicial
proceeding against Mike Flynn we also
proceeding with regards to the Trump
Russian stuff in fact good shot that a
lot of this was a counsellor
intelligence investigation not
necessarily a criminal one counselor
intelligence investigations are not
pending judicial proceedings furthermore
the Supreme Court is pretty exacting
on the application of this law a
prosecutor would need to show that
trumps conduct quote materially impeded
the investigation and even Comey has
said that really didn't happen right
Comey said that he didn't actually do
anything shut down the investigation
okay so that's the provision number one
provision number two is 18 USC 1512 C
and the reason I'm going through this is
because I want people left and right to
have a good picture of what the law is
before they start spouting off nonsense
15 18 USC 1512 C this provision of the
law covers anyone who obstructs
influences or impedes in official
proceeding or attempts to do so it's not
clear an FBI investigation is an
official proceeding and in this case you
actually have to prove intent you have
to prove that Trump actually wanted to
shut this down and typically that
doesn't just mean saying things it means
you have to take quite a substantial
step toward the accomplishment of
shutting it down
and as Flynn has testified he is not
aware that there was really any hard
evidence to attempt to shut down the
Flynn investigation so it would be a
long a long punt to have to have to try
and prove this finally there's 18 USC
1519 this is the provision covering
destroying evidence related to a federal
investigation so this one would
basically say that if you this would you
like specifically with a federal
investigation like an FBI investigation
if frontages for a documents that's one
thing him saying something to Comey is
not the same thing so in other words
just from a backchecking perspective the
idea that Trump committed obstruction of
justice
very very questionable now does that
mean that Trump is pursuing a smart
strategy in response to this stuff
doesn't mean that it's smart how Trump
is responding to it
not particularly Trump's best strategy
here would be to say listen I didn't
mean to impede an investigation I was
just spouting off I spout off all the
time I said some stuff to call me they
freaking deal what you're going to do
about it
I mean Obama did the same thing with the
IRS Loretta Lynch did the same thing
with Comey with regard to the Hillary
investigation I don't see what's going
nuts over this this would be his
smartass strategy and as far as the
Lynch stuff even the left acknowledges
now that the Loretta Lynch stuff is very
damaging because Loretta Lynch basically
did straight out with the lessons
accusing Trump of doing with regard to
combing so if you recall back to last
week James Comey testified that Loretta
Lynch who is Obama's attorney general
told him she wanted the Hillary
investigation referred to as a
quote-unquote matter
he said that he felt nauseous or queasy
I think is where to use with regard to
Loretta Lynch's involvement in the
Hillary investigation now this goes to
Columbia's credibility it really does
because the fact is call me didn't say
anything publicly Comey didn't call out
Loretta Lynch he didn't he didn't
actually stop her from getting what she
wanted in fact he started using the term
matter just like Loretta Lynch on an m2
which suggests that Comey is a guy who
really wants to keep his job I mean he
wanted to his job with Trump he wanted
to keep his job with Obama combing for
all of his rectitude '''l talk about how
he is the spine of moral decency this is
a guy who didn't say much when Loretta
Lynch said I want you to basically skew
this thing instead what he did is he
said listen I think Hillary's innocent
so I'm going to do Loretta Lynch's work
for her so Loretta Lynch won't be
accused of having skewed the
investigation that's pretty crazy right
as bad stuff with regards James coming
the left realizes this is pretty
damaging right now and so here is Diane
Feinstein the Democratic senator from
California basically acknowledging that
what happened to Loretta Lynch is pretty
bad and has to be investigated now the
reason that Diane Feinstein is saying
that of course is because she wants to
be able to say listen
Loretta Lynch should be investigated and
show so should the president that's
smart by Dianne Feinstein they
understand the Loretta Lynch story is a
problem here is the senator Feinstein
from my state California I think we need
to know more about that and there's only
one way to know about it and that's to
have the Judiciary Committee take a look
at that do you think it's worth
investigating if in a way this was
semantics cover given to the Clinton
campaign what was clearly an
investigation being yelled but this is a
separate investigation of course you
know yet and I don't think we should ok
so again this is smart by Dianne
Feinstein what's stupid is Chuck Schumer
he's giving the more honest Democrat
response which is now you know I think
what I do Lynch is fine from pretty bad
right from super bad and you know when
he intimidated Comey that was really bad
but when Loretta Lynch did the same
thing to call me now that was okay
here's Chuck Schumer the Senate Minority
Leader
look I heard what Jim Comey said and he
said he was troubled by it I respect him
a great deal but I haven't heard Loretta
Lynch's side of the story so I'm not
going to come to a conclusion as to who
was right or wrong or whether it rises
to the level that she should come
testify okay so he doesn't think
sometimes I have a trunk should
definitely come testify again this just
demonstrates there's a ton of hypocrisy
on both sides so people who are very
disturbed by what Loretta Lynch did in
the last election cycle
you should be disturbed that President
Trump told James Comey that he hoped at
the Flynn thing would be dropped you
should be okay that's not to say that
Trump necessarily did anything
tremendously wrong it's not said that
Trump did anything criminal yeah I think
that he did something wrong but not for
though I think you shouldn't call the
FBI director into your office and then
tell him you want an investigation
handle the particular way that seems
inappropriate to me but if you are to
serve by Lynch you should be disturbed
by Trump and if you are to survive charm
contribute to stir by Lynch people who
are disturbed by neither are consistent
people who are disturbed by both are
consistent people who are disturbed by
one or the other are wildly inconsistent
and I would suggest that you examine
your partisan bias if you are disturbed
by Lynch but not by Trump or if you are
disturbed by Trump but not by Lynch this
holds true for both sides of the aisle
with all that said President Trump you
know he has his own response to all of
this I already laid out what I think his
response should be what the smart
response would be right which would be
okay you know I'm the obstruction stuff
right look the Trump Russian stuff is
great he already can say that I've been
vindicated on it and he is saying that
his his real response on the obstruction
stuff should be
I didn't legally break the law and by
the way I didn't even do anything to
intimidate Comey because he clearly
wasn't intimidated I was just saying
stuff because that's what I do I say
stuff I'm Donald Trump I mean for God's
sake why are you taking me so seriously
that actually be his smart response I
want to get to how he's actually
responding and why it's not so great in
just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at car
shield calm so sooner or later you know
that your car is going to break down you
know that and it's going to cost you a
crapload of money you hope that it
happens while it's still under
manufacturers warranty and the repair is
covered but if it happens after the
warranty expires then you could be out
of pocket thousands and thousands of
dollars and then you have to decide
whether it's worth getting a new car or
dumping the car you have to go get a
bunch of bids well that's why the better
path is to get extended coverage from
car shield com extended coverage a new
transmission or engine could cost over
five grand even a simple repair to a
sensor can cost a thousand bucks car
shield makes the entire process really
easy you select your favorite mechanic
you can go to the dealership to do the
work there's no check in the mail or
waiting for reimbursement car shield
pays at the mechanic
directly car shields administrators give
you the VIP treatment so if you have a
problem that give you 24/7 roadside
assistance you don't have to have a
separate roadside assistance service and
they give you a rental car while yours
is in the shops you're not left stranded
in the in the cold if your car is three
to twelve years old that doesn't mean
you need high repair bills car shield
administrators have paid out close to
two billion dollars in claims they're
ready to help you right now so right now
go to car shield comm slash Bend and you
save 10% on your program car shield comm
/ bend to save 10% at car shield comm /
been to save 10% save yourself thousands
of dollars in potential repairs plus
again and get that roadside service in
the rental car the whole deal car shield
calm / menu flash vents they know that
we sing and get that 10% off a duckbill
may apply okay
so president Trump is now responding to
the Comey testimony as president Trump
typically does with just frontal assault
I mean it's just full abandoned and this
is where would be really helpful if
President Trump would listen to his
lawyers for once for once but last
Friday in case you missed it because
late in the afternoon President Trump
gave a press conference and at that
press conference he said something
deeply stupid he said he was willing to
go under oath to say that James Comey
had lied there are two problems with
this one
James commies credibility is what Trump
is betting on with regard to the Trump
Russia stuff it's hard to say James
Comey is a liar liar liar liar buddy
totally right about this Trump brushes
stuff very difficult to do that instead
what Trump should have said is
everything he said is basically true but
he misconstrued everything because he
insists on seeing me in the worst
possible light when he saw Loretta Lynch
and Obama in the best possible light
right we now know that Comey did not
write contemporaneous notes over the
Loretta Lynch stuff you didn't write
contemporaneous notes even when he came
to a one-on-one meeting with President
Bush back in the 2000s according to
Comey
so what exactly is is his issue with
maybe like clearly he's just
interpreting me in the worst possible
light that's not my fault that's Comey
small right that's what Trump should be
saying so everything he says I said I
did say but I didn't mean it the way
he's saying it that's what Trump should
be saying instead he goes out there and
he calls call me a liar because
President Trump he is incapable of
backing down from a fight or even
strategically edging around a fight for
his own benefit so instead he says he's
willing to go under oath and all
his lawyers had to just be doing the
full run jean-luc Picard face double
facepalm I mean every lawyer
we all stood been doing the Thomann
straight out the window routine from
Game of Thrones so here is president
Trump saying this at a press conference
on Friday would you be willing to speak
under oath to give your version of 100
percent okay again no no no no no okay
if you are a defender if somebody wakes
from this is not complain 40 chest is
him being aggressive and getting out
over his skis not smart not smart and
really not smart because again once you
go under oath you can be asked anything
and then is Trump the kind of guy who it
means casual with how he talks even if
you want to say he's not a liar he's
casual with the truth okay casual with
the truth is a very kind interpretation
of things the president Trump has said
in the past is a guy who accused Rafael
Cruz of killing JFK okay truth is not
president from strong suit him going
under oath is just a mistake for the
ages if you were to do it which is why
he's not actually enjoyed he's just sort
of saying it but the problem is by him
saying it now the Senate Democrats are
saying well fine here's your invitation
come on come on down and we're not going
to take you seriously until you do go
under oath that's a mistake another
mistake Trump is still hanging on to
this tweet he tweeted out that he has
tapes of James Comey with him or he said
what he really said was James Comey
better hope there are no tapes and first
of all don't try to intimidate James
Comey by saying that you might have
tapes okay James Comey knows this game
better than you do mr. president and
second of all once you say you have
tapes now you actually are an
obstructionist obstruction of justice
territory remember one of the three
statutes that I cited was the statute
that said you're not allowed to destroy
evidence in the middle of a federal
investigation so now what happened to
Trump comes out and he says there are no
tapes well people are going to say okay
we're going to subpoena the tapes and
then what if he says there are no things
people might claim there were tapes
because you implied there were tapes and
you stand you refuse to say there will
not tapes they might say well there were
takes and you destroyed the tapes it's
just not smart not smart not smart
here's Trump talking about the tapes
again when will you tell us about the
more fairly short period of time
are there tape oh you're going to be
very disappointed when you hear the end
so don't worry okay so if we're going to
be very disappointed when we hear the it
why is everything a reality show reveal
here the president just say no there are
no tapes I was tweeting that out because
I think the economy is not interpreting
things correctly I mean again all of
this is so easily explainable if he just
had the brains to to look at this in
realistic fashion as opposed to I just
have to call everybody McGwire who's
disagreeing with me it's just not smart
and especially not tomorrow when you
have Donald Trump jr. than going on
national TV and saying openly yeah my
dad's will call me to back off but
that's not what he meant which is the
proper defense but Trump is now forbid
that defense by going out there and
saying they call me was lying you and I
both know my father a long time well
when he tells you to do something yes
guess what there's no ambiguity in it
there's no hey I'm hoping you and I are
friends hey I hope this happens but you
got to do your job that's what he told
Comey and for this guy as a politician
to then go back and write a memo
oh I sell throws he felt so threatened
he felt he didn't do anything okay this
is the proper defense everybody's not
Donald Trump jr. for saying this is the
proper defense but Trump has already
kind of foreclosed that defense by doing
the whole Comey lied about the liability
the entire situation and then Trump goes
out on Twitter and he says I believe the
Comey leaks will be far more prevalent
than anyone ever thought possible
totally illegal very cowardly okay again
if we're going to talk about cowardly
leaks the president leaks all the time
we'll talk about the legality of
plumbing leaks forget about what you
think economy forget about what you
think Trump this is not smart strategy
it's just not smart strategy and it's
unnecessary particularly because right
now Trump is starting to do some good
things so last week end of the week
president Trump he suddenly nominated a
bunch of conservative judges to fill a
lot of appeals courts vacancies good
this is good
he should be leading with that that's
what he should be talking about you know
even in that tweet storm where he goes
after combing he's talking about the
good in the economy and he goes after
combing how I just talk about what you
want to talk about then one of the keys
to policies like politics 101 is you
always answer the question you want to
answer in the way you want to answer it
you don't always have to answer directly
the question that's being thrown in
front of you but it is it just it's a
mistake
to go directly up against call me this
way because you know the media are going
to be all over whatever Comey says
anyway okay so I want to talk about
homeys credibility whether Comey might
be in danger of prosecution as well plus
should Bob Mueller who's the special
counsel recused himself on the trumped
material we'll talk about all of that
but first you have to go over to Daley
wired.com right now and become a
subscriber so for $8 a month you've got
a subscription to Daley wire.com you can
see the rest of the podcast live plus
you can be part of the mail back this
week actually I think what we're going
to do is my dad and I have come out with
this book I'm the White Sox and I think
we're going to do mail back my dad is at
home the ringman studio so you can meet
my dad and if you have questions for my
dad in the mailbag then you can actually
ask my father questions in the mailbag
this week so go over to Daley wired icon
to come and subscribe and you can ask my
dad anything which frightens maybe you
can ask my father any question you want
we'll be having him in studio assuming
we're in our new studios by then so go
over to Daley wire.com right now check
it out $8 a month but if you get an
annual subscription then you get a free
signed copy of the appli mention books
you get a free signed copy of this book
say it so by me and my father all about
the 2005 at Chicago White Sox season but
mostly just about baseball and
father-son relationships and it's about
three generations of White Sox fans
waiting to see them win a World Series
so it's a great Father's Day gift and
you get a free signed copy signed copy
when you go to jail ey are calm right
now and subscribe great Father's Day
gift so go over there and check it out
or if we just want to listen later go
over to iTunes or SoundCloud and we've
reviewed iTunes we always appreciate it
we are the number one conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you